[موسيقى]
تجربه الجيتار جات لي بتعرفي دبي كلها
مشهوره بالسيارات الرياضيه
وكل شيء الرياضي هنا موجود البلد كلها
فلما جينا فكرنا ان احنا ممكن نخلي نفس
انواع هذه السيارات موجوده في البحر
فهتكون مصدر الجذب للناس
المميزها ان انت راكبه صغيره حقيقيه فيها
بتاع السياره
ممكن تخضى معك حد من رفقاءك جنبك ممكن
تاكله وتشربه ماشيين بالسياره فيها لايت
سيستم فيها
كل شيء بتستمتعي كتير جدا غير ما تكون
راكبه يعني
[موسيقى]
المعلم ممكن تشوفيها هنا موجوده في من
خلال كل المعاني في دبي زي
برج العرب زي عطلانس دبي بالكامل بكل
الابراج دبي لغايه البيزنس
[موسيقى]
دايما بيكون موجود في حد يكون موجود معه
يعني طبعا ما يقدرش يعدي سرعات المحدده بس
في الطبيعي اقوى سرعه لها 100 كيلو في
الساعه
[موسيقى]